six catches 114 yards and one touchdown  it's not easy being born from great news  the numbers on Keshawn are just out of  sight at this point as I believe this is  gonna put him well over 200 yards I've  looked up to a my whole life  third down seven the Trojans  always trying to follow in its footsteps  86 yard t-d pass from Otton to Johnson P  Sean's gonna break something my name  stands for something gives me something  to start for and have a good day June  thanks dad but I'm more than just my  name what a race pretty good  I'm here to blaze my own Trail build my  own legacy work for my future too many  moons at the top you got to be able to  just go straight ahead and close the  cushion you don't need to weep the  expectations are high the pressure  immense yes I'm gonna go you get there  you let me know  do I take his torch or light my own  I told you I was gonna make mode go big  red